يشعر موظفو الخصوصيه في تويتر بالقلق من
الانتشار السريع للميزات الجديده دون
المراجعات الامنيه الكامله التي يتطلبها
مرسوم موافقه لجنه التجاره الفجرليه وهو
ما دعا رئيسه امن المعلومات ليكثنر الى
الاعلان في تغريده صباح الخميس بانها
اتخذت القرار الصعب بالاستقاله كما استقال
كبير مسؤولي الخصوصيه في الشركه فيما قال
موظفا حالي في تويتر ان العديد من الاعضاء
الاخرين في وحده الخصوصيه والامن بالموقع
استقالوا ايضا
الموظفون اعترضوا ايضا على اوامر ماسك في
رساله بريد الكترونيا مساء الاربعاء وهي
الاولى التي يوجهها للموظفين منذ توليه
منصبه في الشركه تقضي ببدء جميع الموظفين
العمل في المكتب 40 ساعه في الاسبوع وذلك
وفقا لصحيفه واشنطن بوست لم تتطرق رساله
ماسك الى تقليد معروف ومستخدم في تويتر
منذ زمن طويل يتمثل بالمرونه في العمل عن
بعد بل اشارت الى حاجه ماسه لكسب المال من
العلامه الزرقاء لتويتر وحذر ماسك في
الرساله من انه بدون عائدات اشتراك كبيره
هناك احتمال ان لا تنجو منصه من الانكماش
الاقتصادي المقبل لجنه التجاره ليا التي
توصلت الى مرسوم الموافقه الاخير لها مع
تويتر في مايو ايار اعلنت انها تتابع
التطورات المتعلقه بتويتر بقلق عميق فيما
حذر مسؤولون سابقون في اللجنه من اننا
مغادره مسؤولي الخصوصيه والامن الرئيسيين
بالاضافه الى بعض التغييرات التي اقترحها
ماسك على منتجات تويتر تضع الشركه
كما خطر تنظيم خطير الخسائر الماديه وتسرب
الكفاءات
والمنافسه مع وسائل تواصل اجتماعي اخرى
بعضها تقليديه واخرى مستحدثه معضلات
تتوالى على الى ماسك ويخشى بشكل اكبر من
منافسين تويتر الجدد لاسيما ان مستخدم هذه
منصه بداوا البحث عن تطبيقات جديده